okay tomorrow night is election night we
will be doing a live broadcast of the
results I hope you will come hang out
with us I will be co-anchoring with
Benjamin Dixon host of the Benjamin
Dixon program he will be sitting right
over there or maybe I'll sit over there
and then we'll sit here you know what it
doesn't matter who sits where but we
will both be here at the desk and we
also i'm going to talk to sam cedar of
the majority report this afternoon he is
going to be doing his own live coverage
and we're going to try to sort of do
part of the evening as a simulcast were
will bring in Sam or he'll bring us in
and it'll littell it's all gonna be
crazy right i mean we with this could be
the beginning of a really really dark
period for the united states uh and it
could also be a very uh interesting
opportunity as i've mentioned to have 12
straight years of democratic presidents
and really to demand from hillary
clinton that we move to the left so we
will be here doing live coverage
analysis as the reports come in starting
what do you think Pat probably seven ish
right i mean that's when the bulk of the
first polls closed yeah there's two poll
closings at six o'clock but about now
eastern time and they're kentucky and
another solid red state i think indiana
so we might as well covered at seven
o'clock i think most coverage starting
at seven eastern ish and that's when we
will be on youtube live that will be the
place youtube.com slash the david pakman
show as well as on the benjamin dixon
show channel and of course sam's channel
and i will remind you in the midst of
all this don't forget to get your 2017
david pakman show calendars which are
comic book themed all original comic
book art all of your favorite
politicians and uh cast members from the
david pakman show unless pad is one of
your favorites in that case he's missing
from it uh but we've talked about that
pets okay uh they're all featured in the
calendar david pakman.com slash calendar
17 gamefly is sort of like netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep
you can buy them for a low use price
there's never any due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a free 30-day
trial at gamefly offer.com / TDPS the
games are shipped directly to you with
return envelopes included there's no
contracts and you can rent games through
the mobile app get the free 30-day trial
for the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s